téléspectateurs il 18h55 les chérries
c'est ce qu'on appelle le Blue Monday ou
le Blue Monday c'est pas la journée des
schtroumps non euh c'est le lundi c'est
censé être le jour le plus déprimant de
l'année ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
normalement tu es au fond du trou donc
si je peux vous donner un conseil passez
cette journé avec les gens que vous
aimez le plus VO pas toi je sais que tu
n'as
personne ceux qui ont toi par exemple ce
soir tu retrouves Laurent ouis comme
d'ab moi j'ai jamais le BL que je
j'adore l' c'est vraiment mon mec
préféré de la télé ça y est et on a
passé un très bon weekend je l'adoreou
on a passé on s'est vu on s'est vu pass
un petit moment ensemble weekend aussi
bien sûr ah ouais ça devient une
hisunch la galette j'avis j'avais pas
encore goûté de galette et Cyril m'a
fait goûter sa galette a goû la galette
il a même et il a même goûté ma
fève et vous savez que c'est Laurent
ruier qui a eu la
fève la qui la il a choisi quel roi on a
pas fait le le jeu on aurait ça se
trouve il vous aurait choisi vous et pas
moi vous AZ pas tiré les rois non pas
les rois vous inquiétez pas je ferai
autre chose pour les autres c'était
parce que eux ils étaient dans le
quartier ils sont passés en bas je leur
dit ça tombait bien quoi non mais en
tout cas vous nous avez très bien
accueilli avait des pâtisseries
partout invité bien
s pouz fermer ta
gueule il est en train de me [__] dans
une merde du tout non je voulais voir
Laurent parce que ah pas moi donc moi on
s' F sûr je voulais voir la et Hugo
voilà et Laurent pour lui parler voilà
parce que j'aime bien discuter un petit
peu PAF avec lui voilà et on a discuté
PAF d'accord voilà un truc à lui
proposer ah ouais ouais il le sait non
mais non mais c'est pas dans le pass et
donc il y avait plein de gâteaux partout
partout partout on était entouré de de
pâtisserie c'était un c'était grand
seigneur c'était
vraiment train de VI ah ouais ou ouais
non puis j'ai découvert votre petit chez
vous ouais ah ben c'est petit chez moi
tu as vu oui oui c'est vrai oui c'est
c'est cozy c'est cozy ouais ouais
vraiment c'est un petit salon
sympathique de peut-être 30 m Carr c'est
vraiment petit sal taille à taille
d'homme ouais c'est ça à taille d'homme
à taille du je vous dis ouais prendre
des Airbnb pour inviter les gens
[Rires]
quand alors les Chéries donc voilà je
vous ai demandé à tous pour qu'on passe
une meilleure journée je vous ai demandé
de me ramener pour vous la vidéo qui
vous fait le plus rire c'est pour vous
aussi pour vous détendre un peu donc
Daniel c'est quoi c'est une
mort c'est une dame quand même je me
retrouve et c'est c'est une vidéo à la
fin rô est cruelle vous allez voir
pasentends pas apparemment au son tu es
déjà
morte j' avis
déjà dans un zo dans le Michigan il y a
un singe qui en a vraiment marre qu'on
le regarde et vous allez voir il visent
très très
bien il vis
très on a les mêmes goûts on a les m des
Bar de r vous allez voir la chute elle
est exceptionn on la connait la chute
frère
exceptionnelle
[Applaudissements]
isou
[Rires]
ministèreors c'est vidé au de passions
la danse et les voitures c'est vrai
j'adore je regarde je la connais pas non
à mon avis
allez oui
[Applaudissements]
fr
aim
beaucoupime
beaucoup lui je le kiffe lui lui tu vois
lui j'ur lui on est
ensemble mais c'est vraiment lui c'est
ma C dans le voilà VI je l'adore je
l'adore quoi qu'est-ce que tu as choisi
alors moi c'est une vidéo de la
personnalité politique que je préfère au
monde par son charisme avant tout à
votre avis c'est qui charismatique c'est
une femme vraiment et pendant elle a
fait une campagne assez extraordinaire
Valée P Valérie j'aiom Valérie
P c'est un remix qui vaut vraiment le
coupattendez pas à ça on l'a pas on l'a
pas décidément c'est pas la saison de
Valé c'est décidément la pauvre Valérie
non mais attendez en plus elle doit en
plus elle doit travailler avec an
dalalgo non mais c'est c'est
insupportable d'ailleurs j'ai décidé
deune nouvelle séquence à partir de très
vite cette semaine sachez-le je l'ai
décidé ce matin au réveil il va y avoir
une squence qui va s'appeler vous ne
savez pas ce qu'on vit pour montrer à
tous les gens qui n'habitent pas Paris
ce qu'on vit dans Paris je vous le dis
non non mais c'est vrai je vous le dis
je vais je vais faire une séquence qui
va' vous savez
pas et tous les
jours je demande aux Parisiens qui nous
regardent de filmer ou des
embouteillages ou des souris ou des rats
ou des travaux ou des trucs dégueulasses
j'en aurais une tout à l'heure ça va
s'appeler à partir de maintenant vous ne
savez pas ce qu'on vit et voilà jusqu'à
ce qu'on change de merre d'accord voilà
je vous dis donc voilà oui donc je vais
le faire j'ai décidé ça ce matin sachez
que dernière nouvelle annalgo ce qu'elle
a fait c'est qu'elle a coupé la place de
l'étoile en deux la place de l'Étoile
c'est pour ceux qui n'abitent pas Paris
c'est genre voilà la place c'est ça
donne sur les champsisés ça donne sur
plusieurs avenus qui desservent tout
elle a décidé de la couper en deux comme
son cerveau
et et donc je vous le dis ça veut dire
que dès que tu arrives sur cette place
tu mets donc mais vraiment je vous dis
3h pour faire le tour de la place quand
je dis 3h c'est 3h c'est insupportable
j'ai un pote ce matin il il é allé au
travail à 7h30 il est parti de chez lui
il m'a appelé à 11h il était encore sur
la place non mais je vous jure que c'est
vraiing truc potes
veut pi elle veut faire pareil donc
écoutez-moi bien il va avoir une
séquence qui va s'appeler vous ne savez
pas ce qu'on vit sur ce qu'on vit à
Paris et ce sera sponsorisé par Gill
Verdez
et merci qu'est-ce que vous avez choisi
vous d'ailleur moi c'est un gendarme qui
se casse la figure en installant un
radar ah je me
rappelle il passe la barrière et ben on
l' donc on le connait merci
moi j'aime bien les vidéos animalières
elles me détendent alors il y en a une
qui allie à la fois vos deux passions
outre la danse et les les voitures c'est
les bananes et les éléphants ah vous
avez une passion pour ban vous aimez
bien les bananes pas de
ouf fr préér les éléphants
non
ça ta vidéo non mais c'est ça c'est ça
ta vidéo non mais tu fous not Gueu non
mais elle est catastrophique non mais
elle est nulle ta vidéo elle est nulle
les chéri vous applaudissez
ça je lui des Bade justement mais' elle
t'ise franchement Patrick alors moi
comme j'aime bien les enfants j'aime
bien qu'il reste dans le monde des
enfants les enfants superhéros alors
superhéros et enfants j'ai choisi cette
vidéo je la sens pas le lancement le
lancement est pas mal franchement le
lancement mal tu as travaillé avec
Bernard
Montiel je l'ai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écouté Mo il fait de la peine il fait de
la peine j'ai hâte de voir la vidéo de
Jack cardos dis-moi e pourquoi tucheté
un beson ce weekend toi exactement on
dirait les Besons de Raymon sur ma vie
c'est
vrai c'est compliment il a fait les
soldes j'ai fait les soldes ouais non
jure tu l'as acheté celui-là hier ouais
je l'ai acheté tu as pas pris làhaut non
achéé weekend je l'ai acheté ce weekend
je t'ai fait un kiff ouais solde combien
celui-là in 40 euh Mo- 50 cel je vous
dis celui-là on le trouve normalement
c'est normalement par que départ tu
regardes et tu regardes les trucs pas en
solde et à un moment le vendeur voit que
tu es une barre
euh le rayon soldé c'est à
droite et là normalement il y a jacard
il fait vous l'avez celui-là tu l'as
pris c'est ta taille c'est ma taille il
avait que sa taille j'ai pris quatre
articles les quatre étaient soldés moins
50 % j'avais dit à ma femme je te
préviens on reste 20 minutes parce que
moi je supporte pas de faire les
magasins faut que ça aille très très
vite ou et donc j'ai réussi à prendre
quatre trucs je les ai essayé les trois
autres bah vous verrez
surprise pas mal c'est du nubuc j'aime
bien non c'est c'est du nubuc non je
crois tu as vu c'est dou hein c'est du
Nub c'est du nubic non c'est c'est quoi
ça l'ont pris dans d'une chaussure
ça franchement il est beau ta femme l'
kiffé ah ouais ta femme elle t'a dit
vas-y ça c'est fait et ta femme tas rien
acheté pour ta femme non mais je l'ai
invité samedi soir euh à dîner dans une
dans un bon restaurant euh les meufs
regardez regardez ce qu'il dit il dit
j'ai invité ma femme à dîner ma meuf je
l'invite à dîner tous les soirs mais oui
h bravo c'est ce que vous VZ dire ça et
lui il a dit j'ai invité ma meuf à comme
un
exp tu veux dire toi tu l'invites tous
les soirs et moi c'est une fois par
semaine c'est ça oua tu étais tout
content je croya tuas seulement des
cadeaux en plus tu te gares en shopping
rien attends
con mais c'est attends rappelle-moi tu
es quand est-ce que tu es allé au
restaurant pour la dernière fois avec
Fatou toi alors il est pas été au
restaurant il est venu à la maison hier
dans ta
gueule vous avez cé invité lui aussi il
est pass
B elle est passante cette rudez
excusez-moi mais c'était à la demande de
ma de ma cuisse de crevette elle m'a
demandé voulez manger des cuisses de
crevette Cu de
Crette me tu l'app ma cuiss de
crevette arrête non mais arrê ça peut
être ch
franchement
de c'est bizarre Comou
FARC ça t'appelle
comment elle qui m'a demandé d'aller
d'aller dîner samedi soir sur cuiss de
crevette mais parce que elle est assez
menue pas très eff et je sais pas ça m'
fait par SAU tu parles de ta
me tu nous parle béchamelle le gar mais
été mangé où indration samedi soir ça
s'appelle la table de cbelle Sibelle
ouais d'accord c'est un très bon
restaurant c'est à Boulogne ah ouaisou
je regardis quand même les prix
euh d'accord je regarde ça je vous dis
ça dans un instant à toutite